hi everyone it's Jerry this is round
nine of the early title Tuesday January
2nd interesting matchup
here kramnick playing White against
Carlson giving
Carlson nearly a minute and a half
Advantage so I'm assuming Carlson right
now is going
to return the favor
we're going to
see there's a bit of a hiccup along the
way in this
event uh Carlson lost a game believe it
was related to the
server so let's see what happens
here I'm guessing Carlson's going to
make a move at around
139 and we're going to have ourselves
some bullet chess with increment still
this is a 3+ one
event so we'll see what we get both
players on 6 and a
half I imagine another 10 seconds or
maybe Carlson even dip below a minute
and say I could do you one
better we'll see oh no he he matched the
time 139 on the
nose and I have been uh viewing this
event he's been
playing these uh these moves throughout
so he starts off
silly and then he starts playing
serus so we'll see how kramnick tries to
punish
this some space for the doctor I'm
forgetting here that I
have the sounds on sorry about
that
so small Pawn Center Queen Knight has
maneuvered as if it's a r Lopez but we
have an open Sicilian here with the
focus on the E5 and now U my attention's
drawn somewhat to this B Pawn
potentially vulnerable now that this is
a new move after the invasive A5 and now
super disruptive H Pawn saying I'm not
uh so keen on castling King side want
attack punch a hole in F3 getting this
guy up to a getting this guy up to
H3 this Pawn is pinned
F2 he's fine with double D pawns that'll
increase his grip over this D4 Square
could see Bishop D4 very soon kind of
irritating putting pressure on the B
Pawn so so yeah expecting maybe King
here okay what's happening after Queen
F3 though did he Overlook Queen F3 I
guess he could defend Rook H6 defends H6
so he's got the bishop pair both bearing
down on the king side and soon I imagine
we're going to have I was going to say
putting the Rook on the G file but he's
going after this guy also pressure here
this Knight is
unprotected Pawn is pinned so where is
there going to be a tactic okay here we
go ripping open
lines we are very close to some tactic
maybe back the bishop off or is there
something more
direct this Knight's going to be
cornered after F3 maybe I don't know
Knight H5 seems very
loose actually on F4 I guess you could
still take here cuz on the capture
there's a recapture and you're on the
Rook see how he plays this this is a
consideration maybe a
[Music]
push maybe even a Capt okay he's taking
with the bishop
so he's just he's winning he's winning a
p there I'm forgetting he's on that
three point uh three times karnick under
20 seconds
now no checks against the king he's got
these two covered by the
Rooks there's this passer here
still very tactical he's getting out of
this check after a pawn
move okay main one threat under 10
seconds for kramnick oh it's a game over
hitting the bishop in G2 a double attack
Bishop is toast we're going to have a
resigner now he's playing on out of
momentum Bishop is
hit Queen could return no well right
here you don't want the bishop to follow
with check a counter punch this check
here nice and cozy he finds a shelter
and he could trade into the winning King
and winning end game I should say this
Pawn is a Gunner a resigner here no no
resigner or win on time but this is now
a completely one position for
Carlson so interesting matchup here uh
yeah feel free to share what you thought
of this one in the comment section below
and um yeah it's been a while since I
posted a video I hope you had a happy
New Year that's all for now take care
bye